πάνόμαστεν όλι σίγουρα ι διαθρομή και πορεία όπου ακολουθησα τα διαφορετικήμεται να όταν ημουν εγώ
σχολιών και φίλοή θα πήγαιναν έξω μέχρι γράαργάτο βράδυ εγώ επρέπε μπορεί να βγαινα μαζί
τους ς ξέρω γοδεκάμειση ένα έκανα φύγω να πάω να γιμηθώ δεν θα πηγαι και
στο επόμενο εξωαστωπούμε γιατί ήξερα ότι έχω προβόνι συν ταξιπνήσω και αυτή η στιγμιαας το
πούμεδόνεισε εισαγωγικά έτσι που ένιωθαν ιδιασκέδαση που έωθαν οι φίλι μου ι συνανθρώπιμούμε κάνοντας αυτό
εγώτε εύρε αποιο μακροπρόθεσμα καταφέροντας να ελοποιήσα αυτό που είχαν στο μυαλό μου θα ν
μια εκανοποίσει μια περιφάνεια όπ θα κρατοσε μια ζωήν αραθυσιάζ το στιγμιαίων για το μακροπρόθες
αυτό που κάννήδια δεν έντυποση μαυλόμενα ότι ενώ πήρες τα οληπιακά μετάλισου μπορούσες να ζεις
σε σεκαένάλλο σύνεφο είσαι δίπλα τους συνανθρώπους του είσεδίπλα στους συναθλητέσου και μεδικές σου πρωτοβουλιες
μεδικές σου πράξεις μεδικές σου εκδηλώσεις προσπαθίς να μαζέψεις και χρήματα για να κάνεις των
ήρων κάποιον άλλων παιδιό πραγματικότητο πως σου ήρθε αυτή έα στα παπούτσια τους ημούν κι
εγώ ιδέα αυτοή ξεκίνησα στην οσία αι διεχαζετεκατρίαγια θλητική ευθύνηκαι τναιοι ιδέα στην οσία ξεεκείσε
το δεκατρία όταν οι οπάπκύπρο ήρθε και διάλεξεντηρίες προσωπικότητες μια εκτον επιομουν εγώ μας έδωσε
να ποτριάνταχιάαζεευρω και μας είπαν να τα δώσουμε φιλανθροπικό σκοπό με όποικανοτρόπο θέλουμε εμείς και
έτσι για νήθηκε τότε ιδέα ν στη ρίξω αθλιτές φιτητές και δώσαμε έν